[Music]
okay if you could just say your full
name into the mic
Mia Jackson Mia Jackson mu Jackson thank
you for being on the show thanks Joel so
you have achieved a goal all comedians
strive for and that is transitioning to
being full-time yes Joel I have
transition to full time it is the dream
of a lot of people you're right and
how's that working out for you
you know what Joel there have been some
lonely nights times like this I want to
quote Langston Hughes life for me ain't
no crystal stair but now it's actually
been it's been interesting it's been um
there's a part of me that feels like fly
by the seat of my pants kind of thing
and there's another part of me that
feels like oh there's an amount of
preparation involved in it cuz this is
one of the things where you know I went
from always having a job to where I knew
you know every two weeks I get paid this
certain amount of money so now it's like
well you might get paid this week or or
you might not or somebody might say
we're gonna send you a check and you
might not get it until three weeks later
when other things were do know it's been
an interesting transition just to you
know it's one of those things because
for years I used to go oh I don't know
if I can ever do it I don't know if I
can ever be a full-time comic and then
when it's kind of forced upon you're
like okay I guess I can't do anything
was there a specific event that made you
feel ready why yes there was Joel there
was a specific event effect so like I
said for years I had a job I had a day
job for a long time I was a corporate
trainer at a company that I don't want a
name cuz they don't get to they don't
get no shoutouts they don't deserve me
to mention who they are but I work for
this one company for years and it got to
a point where we both almost kind of
came to a mutual it was funny because I
mean of course they don't know this but
I'd actually said to myself I was like
I'm gonna quit this job by June the
first and I was like I don't care what
happens I'm gonna quit and then I guess
maybe they picked that up out of the
univer
we're actually gonna make you quit
before there and so um but yeah we had a
new manager and I came in and they were
just like hey you know what we think you
should be in another department and I go
I don't think I should be here at all
and then it was like well but you've
been here for so many years you should
stay and then I just go or you could
fire me and they were just like no no
we're not gonna do that and I go oh yes
you could and that's and so they were
really shocked I think people were
surprised that I asked to be terminated
but I mean I know the game a little bit
I mean my um mother's an HR so I mean
I've been you know I've been in that
situation at other jobs before my mom's
like you're gonna be fine so I asked to
leave and they agreed and I agreed and I
just left and things just kind of went
crazy after that like it was a lot of
cool stuff that happened in a very short
amount of time and I don't think those
things would have happened had I still
been working there so well you were
there I mean almost eight years yeah
almost yeah seven and a half years just
about yeah I mean that's all that's a
long time and a comfortable job I mean
yeah it wouldn't it wouldn't even cuz I
didn't have anything saved at all I was
just like I'm gonna quit I was like I'm
gonna leave you by June first because
it's gonna come to that point anyway and
and and I and for years I would always
I'd even do things where I would write
termination letters and I'd be like I'm
gonna just save this and they'd be like
okay I'm just gonna change the date cuz
I'm not gonna leave just yet cuz things
have gotten better so okay my gonna
leave this day and I'm like alright but
I mean like I said it was it was is one
of those things where if when you making
decisions or if you're kind of waffling
on something sometimes somebody will
make that decision for you I had already
been putting in to put it in into the
atmosphere and into the universe into
the world just kind of going I don't
want to be here like I don't want to be
at this place and there's there's it
doesn't matter how many times I lie in
meetings and pretend like this is the
greatest place on earth oh my god I know
I really know I see what you're saying
and I agree with that and no I know you
know what when I go back to my class and
train them things are gonna be amazing
angry and it only told me sounds I could
tell that same alive until the light
started slowly leaving my eyes
that's when I was like you know I just
think it was one of the things where it
was okay well you've been saying it and
now it's happening and you might not and
it would have been nice to have been
like boom I got you I got control of
this but at the same time I'm sorry all
right I didn't need it to happen anyway
so you kind of help make that decision
for me and now I got to do what I got to
do so has coming from the corporate
world helped you navigate the business
side of comedy
are you finding parallels between the
two yeah there are parallels with um
with with corporate and with with comedy
and I think one of the biggest parallels
that I realize for myself is that I'm a
terrible business person um oh this is
what they meant at work when I got
written up Oh
because Mia doesn't like to meet
deadlines Mia has trouble meeting
deadlines like me but but in comedy
though I actually if it's tough I have
to turn in by a certain date or do
certain things I actually do follow
directions with that because that's
something that I want to do but there
were things that I picked up in that
world that you know held me as far as
like when I'm sending emails to people
you know just knowing how to send a
professional email without sounding like
an [ __ ] you know and you know just
being like hi I'm Mia Jackson but I was
opposed to a I want to work at your club
you know so just kind of putting stuff
together and um and then there's that
part that structure from having a you
know cuz if you go from I do the same
thing at the same time every day to oh I
don't do anything until the night oh
what do i do from this time that I've
been up for years at the same time every
day until night so there's a part of it
where and I'm getting better with it but
but just the structure part of looking
at a schedule and going cuz I used to
live and die by my work schedule it
would be my calendar it was color-coded
and it was if I'm if it's yellow I'm on
a phone call if it's this I'm in a
meeting if I'm doing this is this thing
wrong so that's that's so I kind of have
trying to incorporate those things into
my life schedule now to go okay well
you're supposed to have this call with
this person on this day or if you're
gonna block out time to write it needs
to be this needs to already be in your
schedule I'm
I'm getting there I'm not there yet but
it's happening like a literal calendar
on the wall yeah okay yeah I actually
keep an active an actual and actually
pick that up from one of my BFFs
comedian Landry um but just keeping a
big huge dry erase calendar on the wall
so anytime I have a gig I write the gig
down on the wall and then I and my own
little system is well if it's paid I put
it in black because I'm in the black I
mean I put it in red I mean just to say
I'm not getting paid for it but it's
also I'm building up to it's a black so
I'll put all that kind of stuff in here
you know if I'm going on vacation that
kind of thing I mean which is a
technically vacation anymore but I put
those kind of things in your personal
things and then I also you know try to
keep it in my actual phone calendar to
to just keep up with what's going on in
life but that was something I picked up
from the from my um job to try to keep
myself somewhat organized yeah
definitely on the organizational side
what about branding side because clearly
you have you have a vision for your
branding I mean if you go on your
website me jackson.com mean there's
there's new pictures of you there's
bright colors it's true
pitching yourself is like the likeable
girl-next-door
part i it's so wheat you know and this
is what kind of happened so how how does
how did i bran to my cell cuz i think
four years I don't think I really um I
don't know if I really even had it like
the like the whole branding thing to me
is something that you kind of heard
about in the past ten years or so where
people like you got a brand to you you
got a brand yourself what is your brand
and then I'd be like hey Amir Jackson I
don't know what that means that I'm
thinking oh okay well people are saying
you need to uni it's basically marketing
you know if you think about um well was
that I was listening to some podcast
once and I remember it was this really
great quote and I cannot remember who
said it but this it was some it was a
businesswoman and she said this thing
where she goes branding into space you
take up in people's mind and I remember
going oh that is important sounding and
it makes a lot of sense and it is like
what is my brand so for years I kind of
think I just was kind of
floating along like a my I don't know
what I'm doing and being um it just so
happened like with these um this bright
little bit like you know these pictures
of stuff but like a lot of feedback I
get from people all the time was it like
oh you remind me of my friend you remind
me of this person I know
or and I and I was telling somebody
before I usually get invited to people's
houses a lot after shows sometimes I
don't know if because they think I'm
gonna work for them um because that's
been asked before but um sometimes they
say I want to hang out with you so I was
like hey maybe I'm kind of a girl next
door or maybe I'm that kind of um your
fun friend and so um it just so happens
that my um my boo or BAE as the people
in the streets call call it he is a
professional photographer and so so he
was just like let's do cool fun
promotional shots let's do some promo
shots that kind of he's like what kind
of person do you think you are and he's
like you're fun you're you're lively
people like you so let's make sure your
pictures kind of say that same thing so
they're all very bright and very high
look at me and I have a green background
so yeah I'm you know that kind of thing
so that's that's where it comes from
from just kind of a vision of hey I
think I'm bright and lively let's show
that in these pictures and did that
start within the past year of you going
full-time um yeah yeah pretty much I
mean I and I took something I mean cuz
I'm you know obviously I've been doing
comedy for a long time so I've had
snapshots and you don't have pictures of
me before but you know just your
standard like hey smiling and I might
have my hands under my chin and that
looks like an older meal shot that kind
of thing and I've had you know head
shots but like this is the first time
I've really had like just amazing lovely
or if the children say dope mm-hmm
headshots or promo shots you know so
it's been really fun to go I'll get to
explore this cool silly you know side of
things but in a visual manner you know
do you find yourself writing jokes with
this brand in mind now no not really I
mean I think um I think I think the way
I write I think has always kind of been
that um this little you know I'm a silly
[ __ ] ridiculous person but I think
that that kind of home because some
comics have a certain persona or brand
on stage and then the jokes will just be
geared towards that right that could be
a pigeonhole creatively right right yeah
and so I just think I mean I really just
try to whatever I think is funny or
whatever I feel like you know I want to
give to the people you know I'm like oh
I think that's a good idea I don't know
if this necessarily like if this is if
this is a mere Jackson signature thing
but I just go I think I like this and
I'll just see what where it goes you
mentioned earlier you've quit your
full-time job and became a comedian just
over a year ago and already a lot has
been happening right
is this on just getting booked wise or
television or fanbase let me tell you
something Joel um you're the wind
beneath my wings first of all thank you
yeah yeah it's been a lot of things it's
been um so so when I went full-time in
April of 2014 so one of the first things
that happened I'd actually take the spot
on Nick mom um the year before and mine
was still in the can there were other
people who had taped with me and their
episode was it aired and I was like I
guess mind just won't air but no big
deal it was almost like a week or two
after I no longer had my day job I get
an email from the Nick Milan people
going hey your sets gonna air a month
from now and I'm like what and I'm just
like oh my god like this thing's been in
a can for a year and now it's gonna air
and then um maybe like a couple of weeks
later I got a call from I got an email
from somebody from the AJC and they were
just like hey you know there's this book
that just came out about humor and they
talk about Atlanta being you know a top
comedy city and we know you're a
comedian blah blah can we interview you
and then I go to the AJC and the little
you know on the front page a little
square picture up top is my picture and
then on the inside of the article is a
big you know picture of me
and I'm like oh my god and then maybe a
couple weeks later something else is in
the AJC with my picture like on the
front page of the Living section so I'm
like where's this coming from
anyway even people from my old job I was
like whose paper like this is crazy and
so but yeah but now but gigs that I had
to turn down before I could actually say
oh yeah I'm available that entire week
like I don't have to you know where's
before I'd have to do stuff where I'd go
okay well have a job so I can really
only take a Friday Saturday and Sunday
and even if I take their Friday and
Saturday Sunday gig out of town I still
have to negotiate in and you know almost
bad people with my schedule like hey is
it okay if I leave Friday at 2:00
because I need to go out of town so I
could make it too you know Chattanooga
or something like that or or it would be
old I can work a full weekend but it's
got to be a weekend here in town but no
you know it was it wasn't too often
where I could go I'm gonna be gone
Tuesday through through Saturday or
Tuesday through Sunday so now those gigs
I couldn't take before I could now I
could now take I can do something in the
middle of a week like hey can you can
you do this one night or on a Wednesday
and we'll fly you out sure so now and
now I can do those things and then
another you know big thing was the
audition and all the stuff that happened
with a Last Comic Standing so that was a
that process started in September of
2014 so you know and it was the you know
and even with that it was like well
those are things where if I had my job I
yeah I could steal audition but could
I've been gone for a week in some change
in LA probably not you know so it was
just you know it was just amazing just
how things just kind of went back to
back back and I was telling someone I
said this might be a ridiculous analogy
but I'll tell you anyway I am I said it
was almost like my life before was um
water in the sink just some stagnated
and dirty ass dishwater just in this
thinkin did when it was just like when
you know when my job was like hey we
don't want you to work here like I don't
want to be here it's like somebody just
pulled that plug on it
just with you know it was just like it
is like I'm free I'm clear now I can
just do things you know and even though
there's still the financial aspect of
things were sometimes like I should try
to do but it's been it's been the right
thing you know it's been the right thing
to do and um as many times as I sit back
and go oh man how am I gonna how am I
gonna make it this month then something
pops up and things just seem to be okay
are all these opportunities coming from
just independent or are you having
representation facilitate some of these
opportune so um you know a lot of it a
lot of the opportunities and that's the
thing I'd like to make sure that I say
to the people out there and I just got
it my dramatic voice a lot of it is and
that's another thing I did pick up from
the corporate world is very important is
building relationships and I know it
sounds like one of those you know that's
cliche blah blah blah but it is really
important because I remember when I
first started wooden comedian um he had
told me he said Mia work gets work and I
went you're right he was like you're
gonna find that a lot of your gigs are
gonna come from other comedians so um
even with the whole you know with me
doing the audition for Last Comic
Standing it was because I worked so much
at the punchline you know I have that
relationship establish with them when
they got hey we're gonna do this
audition can you recommend some people
they put me on on the audition um then
there was um like but then like with
some of the college gigs and things that
I have like I do actually have a college
agent so with that you know they you
know hey Mia we're there's gonna be a
you know showcase in this city or this
day do you want to submit okay great and
then I was submitting stuff like that
you know um so some of them have been
kind of you know half and half but a lot
of it is just you know just
relationships people that I know and
reaching out to people and hey remember
I work with you in such-and-such or I
worked at this club before you got any
you know availability I'd love to do
this gig you know that kind of thing so
and when you organize all these context
you have a book of just comedian
contacts
um I mean just just a regular email you
know that kind of thing we're just I
have stuff saved from people I've
contacted over the years but I don't
have an unofficial this is my comedian
spreadsheet okay cuz you had a calendar
calendar but yeah most of that stuff
like that is just contacts I've saved
over the years just for my regular life
so The Last Comic Standing didn't come
from an agent or anything that came from
just yeah it came from the the place of
the punchline recommended me and I went
and did the audition and at the
punchline just put ya at the punchline
and that was in September of last year
and then I got the call back to UM where
you woody
depending on where you live in the
country you would either go to LA or you
would go to New York and so I got the
call for the callback and I'm all
prepared to leave for the callback I
mean they were like actually we're just
gonna invite you to the top 100 so a lot
of people's I really had a good
experience cuz there were other people I
knew like I met people who taped with me
and they were like oh I did two and
three times you know so it was really
you know cool that I got to go right to
the to the top 100 but yeah that was
without having management or anything
like that so well you've performed on TV
a few times yeah but what was your
preparation like for Last Comic Standing
let me tell you Joel I have never worked
harder in my life than I have for last
converse in and I really need to make
sure I incorporate that moving forward
because I got so tired of hearing my
voice and it was but I mean I was just
like I have to bust my ass for this I
was like I'm not gonna embarrass myself
on national television I'm like
regardless look let's say I get on there
and I don't advance then you know my
mindset was at least if I go out he's
got to be on the set I'm not embarrassed
about so from the time that I knew I'd
actually you know hey you're gonna be on
the show I recorded every sit whether it
was five minutes if I was on the road
and I was featuring or if I was closing
I'm recording
every single set playing that step back
and going okay this works this works cut
this out cut this out and then it was
almost to the point of where what I knew
that you know how much time we had to do
on the show okay well if they tell me
how to do three and a half minutes
that's probably gonna be about two
minutes and 45 seconds for TV because
people are because those crowds were so
hot and get so hyped up that you get
applause breaks on stuff that you've
never gotten applause breaks on before
when you go out of like hey I've never
gotten a vote applause Berko my name so
you have to be prepared you're just kind
of like whoa I got to tell some jokes
right now look I gotta keep going so but
it was just really I mean listening to
my set um going back and transcribing
stuff and changed oh I mean I was
changing stuff up until the last minute
and to like right before I taped um my
boyfriend was real helpful with it I
mean he kind of drove me crazy during
the UM process like I wanted to I want
to strangle him he knows that he wanted
to strangle me because he was just like
Mia you got to stay on task with it but
in the long run it was very helpful even
I wanted to slap him but he would he
would call and we would just be on the
phone he go okay run your set run your
set to me like we wouldn't even have
how's your day today my dad's great but
I need you to run your set and I'd be on
the phone running my set just talking to
him going okay tiny tiny tiny and so
he's time him I said okay that clocked
in at four minutes you got to cut out a
word okay that clocked in at three
minutes and 30 seconds okay this clocked
in at blah blah blah I'm like is that
enough is that enough and so it was
timing everything taking stuff out um I
mean anytime I cuz any time I went to an
open mic I would go and play the you
know play my material back and go okay
that joke took 1 minute and 30 seconds
and I know I want to do this joke on the
show so will I be able to keep that one
in and I also do this joke so it was
just a lot of writing rewriting and
listening to myself and then just going
I don't know how people want to hear my
voice cuz it's terrible so oh yeah so I
mean I really I mean it was it was a lot
of preparation but I mean I feel like I
felt like I came out a better comic
as a result because I was like man I
should probably do this all the time and
not just for TV shows like I'd probably
really good if I did this on a regular
basis so so you don't do that on a
regular basis now um not as much as I
was like I still record but like whereas
before I would record and go I listen to
this as soon as my cities or now I'm
like yeah I'll listen to it in two days
I knew it was funny you know that kinda
thing but it it is it's something that I
should incorporate and I would say to
anybody that's you know just even if you
want preparing for TV it's just a good
thing to do because you might say
something you might um you know it might
be one extra sentence that you like man
I never thought to even put that in that
joke before and now I got something or
something might happen in the audience
and you're like this is something I can
use and so I mean there was a joke I've
been doing the same way for a long time
and then right before the show I am
because another person I Ram I said with
was Landry and so we're FaceTime and
he's like I ring your send and I just go
okay and I'm doing the set and he's like
have you ever thought about taking this
thing out and enclosing it this way and
I'm just like oh my god it's like today
the day of like I'm taping that night
and I just go that's actually really
good a lot of my comedic instinct is
going that might work and then I closed
that joke just like that I was like boom
like I was legit Greg and I've been
doing it now in the club since then I'm
just like why haven't I never doing that
way before so yeah so yeah there's a lot
of a lot of work that I should probably
do all the time
could you see other comics like
preparing backstage and that intensely
yeah like I like there were some people
it was it was interesting you saw people
who were loud and playing the whole time
and just kind of all over the place me
you saw oh the comments just kind of off
in the corner and just mouthing stuff to
themselves over and over you know you
got some people who were just talking
just out of nervousness like we're
having a conversation but I'm here but
I'm not really here I'm here but I'm not
here and me you know but yeah a lot of a
lot of me a lot of mouthing of things
and a lot of I'm gonna go off to this
corner by myself and look at my notes so
yeah you could see that a lot yeah I
don't know if you
about him when his crazy his idea though
I'm sure they did it but being there it
was a lot of mouthing and from a
competitive standpoint I mean was there
a nice community or was it all like
every man for himself you know what I
think there might have been a little bit
of both I mean it was it was this thing
but there was the experience of oh man
we're all here like this is this is
really cool so you know you would meet
people and talk to people I am and I
hope this goes great and you meet other
people who are just like I am ready to
take over the world you know amazing
this will be if I win not to you but I
waited the show time just like chill out
like this you need to relax like it is
not that see you're serious but you sir
need to calm yourself down you know so
you would see a little bit of that you
know and then but for the most part to
me it felt very if it was a positive
experience I mean people you know there
are obviously people who were probably
secretly going around like I want to win
and I'm gonna win and I think you should
go in there with that attitude but
everybody seemed to be pretty supportive
and where are you from where are you out
of okay great I never been out to
Atlanta or if you couldn't my city some
people I still you know we still text
and keep it so it's like hey Baba most
of the time it was did you get your
check-in but you know just kind of keep
it in touch and you know cuz we you know
shared this unique experience at the
same time so but there are people who
are like I know we're gonna work
together one day you know so that was
cool and there was one comic who had
done it the season before me and I had
contacted her and I was like hey any
advice and then she was like look make
sure you get a damn good tape out of it
and she was like that's what you want
and she's like cuz you can't you can't
predict the outcome you know and and
that's another thing that I've learned
over the years with comedy anyway I mean
it's it's very easy I think to go in and
and compare yourself to other people I
think is very easy to go well how did
this person get this thing and I didn't
or how did this thing happen um or if I
go on the show I've got a win cuz there
were people who left crying you know
what I mean like there are people who
really really disappointed but yeah it
would have been nice to have you know
continued on but at the same time I was
like you know what I know I got a good
tape out of it unless they go back and
add things in and take stuff out but in
the very least I know that I performed
well and if they use the sin that I did
which where I performed well I think
both times then it's like okay when I
have two cents that I could use to get
more work and do other stuff so that's
kind of you know cuz now it's like well
I can sing you a clip besides this thing
I did on YouTube you know so that was
kind of my thing was like I just want to
go get that good tape I just want a good
tape like that that was what I wanted
and I feel like you know that's what's
gonna happen
well how does the high coming off Last
Comic Standing compared to you opening
up for Chappelle or Amy Schumer um it's
a very it's God it's such a different
high because the you know doing the
Chappelle thing like gosh it was just I
can't even even now and that was that's
now been in two years ago two years ago
this yeah um next month it'll be two
years and I just know getting a call and
going what like I'm I'm gonna go do cuz
I'm it was Marshall Marshall from a
laughing school and that's who I was I
hate me he's like what are you doing I'm
like I've been target right now I'm
ready to go to a gig and he's like I was
too bad he's like for you in this
weekend knowing I'm like oh I've got
another gig he goes so you wouldn't want
to open for Chappelle I was like okay
I'll cancel everything I'm like
absolutely and so get in there you know
it was like that was his finger it was
so unexpected said you know where to me
it was like hey I'm just doing another
show but they never you know but it was
just like I just opened this crazy
and then I but I just feel like I still
got more work to do I'm still doing
other stuff and then um and because I
you know the preparation for that was
just well I've been doing comedy all
this time I'm just doing a set but it
was still like this is Dave Chappelle
and then for you know Amy Schumer it was
like well I just been doing comedy all
this time and I'm opening for Amy
Schumer but you know it was like ooh
that thing happened like that's cool and
then the high from the show very
different because it was just this
build-up from
months and months you know going from
September to March and just being like
okay this is gonna happen because it was
it would be on just performing it was
also oh I'm going to the gym all the
time
I'm not eating carbs after 4:00 I'm
doing all this stuff because I was like
I'm not gonna have a double chin on
national television you know it was like
I've got I want to look great I want to
do all the stuff so it looks like I'm
doing all this still to prepare them
it's like you go I'm doing this step
this step this step been the pinnacle is
now on the show and it is huge high and
then afterwards you're like well do I
keep going to the gym doing do I keep
writing joke and I now eat carbs after
four you know so deal was that that
experience of going so that that was a
that high was very like that drop was
just pretty much like when it was over
it was so it was so intense it was so
intense to where when it was done I just
remember going what do what do I do now
like I didn't even know what to do for a
few days I was like okay I gotta go home
and I gotta get back on stage and I
think I think I just need a break for a
few days from comedy I was like I just
need to calm down cuz I cuz the other
shows huge huge experiences I mean it's
Dave Chappelle is Amy Schumer but like I
said it to me it was still like okay
well I'm gonna go do a sec I'm just I'm
performing and I performed now the
show's over I'd go home but this was
just like like I said but it was that
much I mean those would have been
different if I knew if I knew in January
that he role and you and you're gonna be
open here for Dave Chappelle than it
would have been okay I'm preparing a
repairing or preparing but it was like
oh it's this afternoon gonna be open for
trade name Chilton I was like okay I
just you know game time I just got to go
I just got to go but this was like
building building building building and
then that release but it was just a it
wasn't until I left that I was like man
that was an intense experience it's like
that wasn't intense in Spears but I mean
for a few days I was just like I don't
want to watch comedy I don't want to
hear comedy I just need a few days of a
break that is all I want so like coming
down from that was a very it was a
different coming down you
mmm-hmm but all I mean all great
experiences but that was just like so
just involved so involved
well like would Last Comic Standing
rebuild a be backstage with Chappelle
and Amy and Network a little bit talking
yeah like with the UM with the Chappell
thing um I mean obviously he's Dave
Chappelle so he got his own huge green
room that they allowed me to go into I
was in my own green room that had a
couch and chair mm-hmm and a mirror I
was like Hello who else is lucky um and
but it but later on during the night of
a friend of mine came and because she
talks to everybody in the world they
were like oh the comedians your friend
in LA why is she in here with us and she
was like I think she's scared to come in
here no like no jellinek gonna come back
so I was in a green room with Mema
nearby just hanging out and talking and
he was just super cool and he's like
he's like so who are you cuz he came
late and you know and I go cuz he saw me
walking in the hall earlier and he's
just like hey and I'll just go hi and I
I don't even have a hard to be like I
opened for you earlier I'm just like oh
no I to go and say this to Dave
Chappelle and so um later he was like no
who are you now I go oh I will call me
but I'm open for you earlier tonight
thank you thank you for doing that only
appreciate he's like cool and so he's
like alright cuz he was like why are you
so quiet I'm like you're Dave Chappelle
what am I supposed to be talking about
nothing I say you're gonna be as
hilarious as you say you know but yeah
but he was still super cool and um just
kind of you know it's I don't know if
you could I mean I I'm a difficult time
networking with people in general so for
me it was just more like I'm just glad
to be invited to the party I don't want
to be like hey Dave here's my number
like I wasn't that kind of person but um
but when Amy I'd actually met her a few
years ago at the punchline when I think
it was around of time she maybe um it
might have been one of her first times
headlining at the punchline and so this
was when they were bringing a lot of do
for people to host you know the hey if
this person hosts an 8 o'clock on
Fridays persons hosting at 10:00 and
this was just one of night so I happen
to do both of the shows and so when I
came in she was like oh she's like cool
nice you know nice to meet you she's
like jiggles yeah you're cool you're
you're a cool person she's like cuz a
lot of people they've had coming here
Ben
she's like people became kind of cocky
and he had a head of tools and she was
like you just seem to be really like
regular and she's like and you seem like
a you're a comic she's I can tell you
were comic and I'm like gee thanks you
know and so um and then we had a cool
experience of them when we met because
um there was another comment I don't
want to say his name he's an actor and
he burst into the club and asked if he
could do a gift spot and they were like
we have to ask the headliner so he comes
into the green room with his friend and
then the friend is just like oh I saw
you performing earlier and I go okay
thanks he's like you're funny and I know
okay thanks and then a friend is like so
I could get you pregnant and I go I'm
okay I think I'm alright moving a
pregnant free life about I don't even
know you
actor dude is looking at a me and he's
just like you so cute I just want to
kiss you in the mouth and then and then
we're sitting there and Amy's was like I
saw this point we both have kind of
shifted from side to side and she's like
oh I saw and I saw star moving but I'm
just moving and she starts talking
through her teeth and she's just like
cuz you aren't leaving are you she's
like you're not you are not leaving and
I go no I'm no I mean she's like I know
cuz you're staying back here and I go I
am stay and so that's how I met her now
that I think I friended her on Facebook
and then um you know whenever she would
come to town like I remember one time
she was working man another club and she
asked when it comes you know Mia Jackson
and he's like yeah and she goes she in
town tonight can you do you have her
number can you call her and then so he's
like Amy's here so he brings her to the
punch line and she's like hey we gotta
work together at some point is so when I
saw she was coming to town I just hit
her up and I was like oh my god I'm like
I would love to come you know so sure
are you gonna hang out or anything she's
nobody you just want to do a spot I'm
like oh okay
so yeah but she's been really helpful to
me to just as far as home so networking
with
like I kind of already you know we
already had each other's information
that kind of things so when I needed
stuff I mean really I don't need
anything it's just been more like advice
cuz even before I went to the show I
asked her I'm like I know you did it so
you know you need advice and she was
just like just have fun cuz she was like
just know that you can't you can't do
anything about the outcome so you just
got to do as well as you can do and I
was like okay cool so she's been very
helpful with stuff like that well you're
definitely I have zero reservations
saying you're the most prominent and
most talented female comic coming out of
it land let's stop it right now oh gosh
that's the fact that's why that's why
you're on here and Amy Schumer is at the
top of the game as far as female comics
go everything she's doing I mean did she
have any wisdom based on her experiences
at the two levels um you know like the
biggest buy she gave me so far was the
stuff about last comic you know just
kind of being like make sure you do this
make sure you do this and they're gonna
love you it's gonna be great you know
and then then I had a little management
situation as well that she gave me some
advice about - so bigger I mean super
helpful like really I can't even begin
to say how helpful she was about that
well yeah but super super super cool I
mean just you know but just kind of you
know I don't even she'd have a tell me
anything directly but I think he was
just watching how she handles her career
it's been a you know a really cool thing
to see just as a as a female comic
because it happened so much you know to
where people like oh your chick comics
oh I don't know what you're are you
gonna have an attitude when you get on
stage tonight or you're gonna do this I
was really cool like to see somebody
like her just going out and be like I'm
a woman I love the fact when I'm a woman
and I'm gonna kick ass with it and I'm
still gonna be funny
and you're gonna respect me and that you
know what I like that that she's able to
to do that so it just that is very
inspiring so you know seeing that as a
she didn't have to tell me it's an
inspiring thing to see to go man I like
how she handles her career and the
trajectory she got on Last Comic
Standing and they kind of yeah from
there you see similar
trajectory with you um you know it would
be nice to have a similar trajectory but
I also try to be very realistic about
things as well just because I mean I
don't know what's gonna happen you know
because there are people who have been
on the show where you like oh that
person was on Last Comic Standing the
end the end you know you have some
people where you're like man this person
went from Last Comic Standing you know
she was one of times influential people
and I mean you got other people who what
was it um you know I know it's comics
who went on there who you know have
Comedy Central specials if they went on
a half sitcoms and all this other cool
stuff you know so I think it's um I mean
I think a lot of stuff also has to do
with timing so we'll see what happens
with timing you know we'll see if the
world is ready for an adorable black
lady yeah you not only being a female
but a black female a black female John
what a game a comedy game I mean yeah
you grew up in Columbus Georgia in a
black neighborhood it's true it seems
just based on observation you tend to
gravitate towards the white side of
comedy and I hate that I hate that
comedy is segregated like right but it's
hard to ignore I mean and there are some
comics who tend to only go towards their
race there tends to go the opposite I
mean do you find yourself wanting to
branch out into the urban market at all
are you comfortable in your lane hey
Joel this is an important thing that the
world needs to know about Mia Jackson
um I'm black you know what I mean and
I'm very much well aware of that cuz I
mean this is real talk I mean like real
like I know people who are black comics
who they would never do open rooms they
would never do them and and there's also
I think sometimes you meet people who
and I hate saying things like this but I
think you meet people sometimes we were
like well I'm black but I'm also not um
what's the word
I don't have to be a black comic that
kind of thing and I don't I don't feel
that way I mean I feel very much like
I'm a black person I'm a black woman I'm
a black woman that grew up in a black
neighborhood with black parents and I
went to black schools my whole life
until I went to college and I think um
but to me I think for me it's really
more about what my comedic sensibilities
are I mean and I don't think that I'm
it's not that I can't to do urban or not
that I won't do because I have I've done
that kind of stuff before not not a lot
but um I think it's just when I started
I started off as a mainstream comic and
I just kind of stayed in in that world
but I mean but growing up like the
comedy that I love the most and when I
watched the most I mean I grew up on Def
Jam you know like that was the stuff
that made me want to be a comic like I
watch the Def Jam all the time I watched
comic view all the time I that's what I
wanted to do and then when I started um
when I started getting interested in
stand-up in general I mean by that time
I think Def Jam was off the air I think
I mean he was still on but then I just
started watching stuff on Comedy Central
and I was like man you know I really
like a lot of this stuff that I'm
singing on here you know I like the like
the writing I like you know I like what
I'm hearing I'm like oh I've never known
this side of comedy really and so I kind
of you know I was just like okay and so
when I but when I first started on me I
started off in like a mainstream open
mic and I think it's just it just so
having that's just where I started you
know but have I doing urban shows yeah I
have I been booed yeah yeah I have been
I've been embarrassed
terrifically oh I have but then I've
also had over shows where people were
like I like you you're different and I'm
like okay cool I mean I'm just I'm just
me a Jackson would you say the
experience of getting booed maybe made
you apprehensive about going
hell no I didn't make me apprehensive
about going back no no cuz I mean I know
they didn't make me apprehensive at all
I think it's just I think at this point
I've done so much mainstream that I
think that's just kind of where I am but
I mean I'm okay with it like when I get
in front of mainstream crowds
I still feel there's very much a
response
me as a black person to be like well I'm
not gonna be up here acting a complete
fool for you guys I'm not gonna
tap-dance for you like I'm not doing
that like I'm gonna let you know that
what I represent is I represent me you
know I represent my life I represent my
family I represent here Jackson is a
black woman that grew up in Columbus
Georgia that graduated from the
University of Georgia that has a degree
in communications and I like to read and
I'm gonna do that stuff and I'm gonna
talk about that stuff on stage but it
doesn't make me any less of a black
person like I don't have to work at
urban room to be like oh you a black
comic like I don't have to do that I
mean I can't do it if I could say I've
done you know and most of the times when
I work um quote-unquote urban clouds if
I do what I've done it more in like a
church environment or I've done like
like clean shows and things like that
but I'm not saying that I don't identify
with things cuz I mean I like as I grew
up in I mean there are people in my
family who lived in poverty I stayed at
those people's houses grew and you know
growing up I started staying at my
family's house I mean it's like I know
the experience you know what I'm saying
but I just think it's just that I just
happen to gravitate towards more of a
mainstream kind of thing I don't think
anything wrong with it but I do hate the
segregation of comedy I hate that it's
not a and but I can say that for any
side I think like for people who were
just like Oh I'm alternative I don't do
that kind of comedy I tried to talk
about killing puppies you know all right
you like killing puppies you know this
you cannot kill puppies and still be
funny but I mean I know people who are
in the urban world who are like man I
could never do mainstream rooms like how
do you do that like I would never do
that I mean I'm cool with a lot of urban
comics you know but I know people who
were like I would never my comedy just
won't translate you know but it kind of
sucks I mean especially when I read
historically about how all that stuff
came to be in the first place because
there was a time when it wasn't even
technically an urban scene you know what
I mean it was a time if you look at the
comedy boom where you just performed you
just went to wherever you could tell
jokes men there's always been obviously
in urban world or whatever but I mean I
think as far as that being a whole
bhishan rose comedy i mean i think that
was something that probably happened
more like in the late eighties early
nineties kind of thing and i think it's
just a thing that's that stuff but i
don't it did that does bother me and by
it bothers me that i mean not for myself
that but it just bothers me that like
it's not a like that the comedy scene is
so segregated in general like it really
is just a troublesome thing to me and
it's like well why can't it just be
everybody performing wherever all the
time and it doesn't really matter but
you know the reality is that that's just
not not the case and you said it started
late 80's early 90's do you think that
was around like the def jam yeah i think
so i mean like i said if you if you read
anything about um you know i'm out read
hope i mean i read a lot so just um I
mean I'm reading a book now called on
the real side by a male Watkins and it
talks about just the black comedy and
not like you know not black comedy Elton
John wrote pajama but african-american
comedy and african-american humor and
and just how that started from slavery
through the minstrel shows to you know
the sixties and seventies and to where
you know Richard Pryor came out of that
and then there's this big thing that
happens and then it kind of coincides
with the comedy boom - so um but yeah I
mean I do think that um um I mean cuz it
was obviously a historical tradition
behind him I mean but I do think that
urban as a genre probably got more
popular like a round of time there were
things like comic viewing in Def Jam
because there was a market for it you
know I mean because by that time like
the the big boom of the 80s was kind of
over so then you start having all those
segmented markets live all right now we
got alternative scene now we have an
urban scene and we have all these
different things that have that have
happened so so you've been you've been
in the comedy game for a minute now um
do you see these kind of segments as you
say are there more and more popping up
or are we kind of starting to overlap
each other I mean I think there's some
overlap I think there's all I think has
always been overlap I think they're all
we'll be um overlap but um I mean I
think now if anything is popping up as
his own separate segment or genre of
comedy would be um anything that you see
this web-based you know YouTube
Instagram and Vine so I think that's
becoming his own separate thing but I
mean but even in that though you still
have people that are you know you got
you more mainstream stuff he's actually
more stuff anymore alternative still but
I think that's kind of his own sub-genre
of comedy
you're an old-school comic but are you
starting at a point now where you're
like alright I need to get more of a web
presence I need to step my game up on
that end because you know as we as weird
cuz I actually started at a time where
um I I started a time where they were
still sending out VHS tapes when I
started comedy like it was like you
still store and then it wasn't it was
not so much and then it was VHS to to
DVDs I mean there it was it was very um
it was still you mail actual DVDs the
people you mail actual VHS tapes to
people which I mean that was in 2002
2003 so it was like you would think we
would have advanced a little bit so so I
was you know I was around when people
first started using my space to promote
company because I remember you know
people being like have you heard of this
Dane Cook guy he uses this thing called
myspace and I'm just like what the heck
is MySpace and then all of a sudden all
these comics started using MySpace and
it was like oh
use Facebook and people started using
Facebook or use Twitter so I was kind of
you know around when I saw the whole
transition from oh we're doing you know
DVDs to okay well now I can actually
upload stuff online I remember having
conversations with comics who started
years before me who were like oh I'll
never use this Facebook thing I'll never
use this Twitter thing and that out what
is this crazy stuff you know so I think
I started at a time to where I'm like
well I knew a little bit about the old
soos old-school stuff not all of it but
enough to where I'm like well I'm also
young enough in it and young enough as a
person to where I'm not against
technologies
whether with it whether and I mean yeah
I think I mean we're presence I do think
it's important now I mean because
somebody should be able to find you
because again even if you look at a lot
of statistics know most traffic
especially among the african-american
community a lot of us done mobile so
when people are using Facebook when
they're using Twitter when they're using
Instagram most people are using it on
their phones they're not using it
sitting now and their computer so I do
know that having a web presence is
important I know having a website is
important I know you know trying to and
in it and I hate doing it not not even
from being an old-school coming but I
just hate doing because I'm like I have
to post pictures of things today like
who cares you know I doesn't matter
really care about this stuff but then I
have to go alright keep in mind it
people are looking at their phones all
day long so yeah let me post a picture
let me put something on Facebook or let
me go and you know tweet let me do
something just so that somebody knows
I'm here because you do have to to
interact with people so it's important
do you think getting your face out on
the social media side is more important
than maybe moving to an LA or New York
oh I think New York is still important
like I think I think I mean you have
people who I think become successful
being where they are because I mean I
can film a video right here and it could
go viral that that can still happen but
I do think I think it's still important
like - I think LA and New York are still
huge it's just a matter of as a comic
which one you're gonna decide to go to
because if you want to be you know real
deal stand-up you go to New York you
wanna be you know if you understand I've
been in do TV stuff didn't you go to you
go to LA so well I know you have filmed
TV in LA are you leaning more towards LA
you know what ad there was a time where
I I don't know where I want to go
exactly I mean it was a time where I was
like man I should probably go to LA
because I'm adorable but in the past few
months I've gone to LA a few times I've
been like I
like being here and I'm I don't like the
traffic I don't like I mean it should
not I mean Atlanta traffic is bad but it
should not take two and a half hours to
get somewhere that is only 30 minutes
away or 45 minutes like that's just
excessive mm-hmm and it's hot and
they're just people everywhere I'm like
why are you not home like it is one
o'clock in Africa what are you doing
right now there's people everywhere in
New York to be yeah but they're not in
cars yeah I mean they are it does
sometimes smell like pee but um I can
live with a little pee it's in New York
I mean I don't there's a part of me I
just I don't know I would I would if I
don't have to move but I mean if right
now I guess if I had to choose I would
I'd probably lean more towards New York
I mean I'm not against LA I just don't
think I could live there full-time
like if somebody said hey Mia we have a
TV show and you only have a tape and be
here for six months I probably could do
that without running out into traffic
but um well you had a timeline with
quitting your job you're like June first
I'm quitting is there similar with
moving somewhere just a timeline mom the
timeline what comedy is really based on
my lease so if my lease is up May 31st
and I'm like I gotta make a decision by
May 31st but if my lease is not up until
the end been no decisions are made but
now you've made me think about my life
at all and I don't want to make any more
deadlines well I know that's just a
stand up side I mean is acting another
you you want to pursue you know here's
the thing with acting I'm not an actress
at all I am people have said to me
before like oh my god who'd be like a
really good character you could be a
really awkward ridiculous nervous Brett
best friend because that's the kind of
person you are and in real life and I'm
like I could but then I have to remember
lines so if I were to act I don't want
to do commercials so that I could just
do I want to say this and go
it sure is delicious hmm like that's
what I want to do I don't want to have
to know like fools all right well you
definitely have
you have very high standards for
yourself I mean moving forward I mean
just think about Amy Schumer how she has
her own show now and she's a nationally
touring standup is that kind of the
paradigm you would like if you were to
do acting it's my show my rules yeah
like if I were if I think if I were to
do any kind of show I would probably
lead more tours like a talk show kind of
thing because I do enjoy talking and
harassing people
and I usually get people to admit things
to me that they never planned on it
meaning not that I try to get them to do
it but I've been places before where
I've been at conversations with people
that I'm like oh I remember having a
conversation with this guy once and he's
just like hang on lie to you I cheated
on my girl when I was like whoa and I'm
like we just really met two minutes ago
and I'm like why you tell he's looking I
feel so bad about it and I just can't
even believe it happened and I go mm-hmm
but things like that happen to me all
the time when I think the people admit
things at me and I'm like I'm probably a
really good talk show host because
people just tell me stuff and I don't
mean for them to tell me and then I go
tell something I'm talking to the guy
like tell me more like why did you cheat
on her
are you sad so I think if I were abused
them I'd probably want to go more of a
talk show kind of route um but I mean my
main being is like I said I'd if I were
a new TV talk show but then otherwise I
would just want to I don't want to
travel I would love to just go around
doing stand-up I would love to like have
a you know people who actually paid to
see me as a you know to be like Mia
Jackson we love me a Jackson like that
because I mean and see and you know and
from having done the shows with
Chappelle and doing the shows with Amy
it's like man this is their crowd like
these people love them these people have
come to see them like I think that to me
that would be like a cool thing was I
was like I paid to see Mia Jackson I
don't know me you Jackson but I know her
common you know versus well we came to
the show because Mia's our daughter
you know me as my sister I love me we're
gonna go support me because we know her
it'll be nice of somebody to go man I've
been watching her for years and that's I
love me I just want see me
say so well I love me a Jackson you know
and the world will soon know the comedy
that is me a Jackson is there anything
else you want the world to know um what
I want the world one I don't want
anybody to judge me from us my
statements that I made about um being an
urban cop cuz I don't mean that if I
don't want it I'm not trying to start
wars I just I wanted to be clear that I
started in mainstream and that's just
kind of where I ended up but I'm a black
person but beyond that what I want
people to know is that uh I am on the
interwebs I can be found at Mia
jackson.com I'm also on Instagram and
Twitter at Mia comedy I'm also one of
the Facebook's there's a fan page that's
comedian Mia Jackson but yeah so yeah
I'm all social media all that good stuff
and so I'm always somewhere performing
around town doing something so check me
out people
check me out I think I'm think I'm I
think I'm funny hopefully you will too
well it's been my pleasure to have you
on the show thanks Joel Thank You Mia
Jackson
[Music]
high breath